Xbox boss Phil Spencer said you won't
need to worry about Microsoft investing
in third-party exclusivity deals are low
rise of the Tomb Raider for much longer
since that isn't the plan for the
company long-term Spencer told Chinese
games publication game core as
translated by Jill shockers that first
party games will now be Microsoft's
first priority he says my strategy is
more around our own first party
franchises and investing in franchises
that we own and probably fewer exclusive
deals for third-party content I want to
have stronger party relations but pain
for many third-party explosives isn't a
long-term strategy rise of the tomb
Raider's the only current example of
Microsoft third-party exclusivity which
is launching significantly ahead of time
on xbox one and xbox 360 this November
before comes to pc and ps4 next year
Sony on the other hand currently has
third-party exclusivity deals with
destiny street fighter 5 and call of
duty the last of which previously had
their exclusivity deal with Microsoft
let me know what you think about Sony
and Microsoft fighting for third-party
exclusivity and for everything else new
and gaming be sure to stay tuned to
games but